present the next award the superlative
actress superlative she gave me that
word herself who portrayed the oppressed
young moon and rumors of you and the
young actor who portrayed the
irrepressible ferris bueller in Ferris
Bueller's Day Off
Jelena Bonham Carter and Matthew
Broderick
Matthew and I meant to say something
witty at this point but we've dried so I
think we'll just get on with it the
nominees the best achievement and
documentary short subjects are debonair
dancers Alison nice Trellick producer
the Masters a disaster Sonia Friedman
producer red goons sunflower in a
hothouse Thomas L Neff and Madeline Bell
producers aren t wife Blatt producer
women for America for the world
Vivian Burton ro producer winner is the
winner is women for America for the
world with the inversion road producer
what a wonderful recognition of all the
people who work so hard to stop nuclear
war our country is only as good as we
make it in the United States last year
10,000 children died as a direct result
of poverty not one cute person not one
human being on earth would need to
suffer starvation if we use the
resources every year of just four days
of world military spending let's improve
our efforts to care for each other
I proudly accept this award on the
behalf of the women in my film and on
behalf of all the courageous people all
of you who speak up for true security
for our nation and for our world thank
you so very very much
ladies and gentlemen mr. Richard
Dreyfuss